packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on take it
easy because it's time for my ultimate
slow cooking
[Music]
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chef's arsenal not only is it
easy it's also an incredible way to
transform meat into mouthwateringly
melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks to
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity slice
alongside the bone straight down you can
see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates i'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
season these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top
we'll start coloring that in
[Music]
really important to give the beef short
rib a really nice sear
if you didn't brown the meat off it goes
in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a
heaped teaspoon of tomato puree
i'm just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it cooking out that smell of
puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs
red wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark rich
intensity
look at my garlic
that is just gonna sweeten everything up
incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they braise
from the bottom and steam from the top
into the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
in she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish it's a light cured pancetta
we want nice thick
lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not gonna slice them
i'm just gonna cut them in half
but look at the color on those lardons
now
all the whites raw fat have disappeared
the lardons have shrunk
right down
and all we've got there now is the
proper bacon
mushrooms in
beautiful
so the mushrooms get seasoned from the
bacon
i'm pan frying these separately to the
beef so they remain crisp another
different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now
this is like christmas day for me when
you unwrap that fall wait you see what's
underneath it
[Music]
wow
they smell
incredible
lift and place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
when all that nice pureed garlic coming
through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing
flavor
scrape
all of that
off the sieve
nice
and then
just start
sieving all that lovely braising liquor
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce
and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on
your bacon
and your mushrooms
useful
be generous with these mushrooms i'm
telling you
they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley all that freshness
over those amazing ribs incredible never
ever be embarrassed about going to your
butcher and asking for cheap cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs
with bacon and mushrooms
mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients
i use chestnut mushrooms with the beef
short ribs because i love their firm
texture and nutty taste but there's a
huge range of other mushrooms that are
great for slow cooked dishes
[Music]
and when it comes to buying them there's
one expert green grocer who's a fountain
of knowledge borough marcus fred foster
started off on the dead storm in pimlico
really he had a salad stall
with over 20 years of experience he
could actually write his own mushroom
encyclopedia
mushrooms as soon as you pick them
the moisture starts coming out of them
so you need to buy them when they're
fresh certain products you smell for
flavor and they tend to be fruits
mushrooms don't smell nice at all they
smell kind of metallic really
so you have to use your eyes as your
guide of what you buy with mushrooms
really really important wild mushrooms
are literally grown wild in the forest
they're just quality wherever they are
this is morel mushroom
a fantastic product so hard to find in
the world it's almost got an apricoty
type of flavour earthy woody and of
course as you cook it the flavour
increases
for extra flavor and texture highly
prized morels are ideal when added to
slow cooked stews and casseroles as are
the trumpet de la more which have a
deliciously rich flavor
another wild type to try is the
chanterelle its subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process it's
with a soft brush don't don't use water
never use water with mushrooms it
deteriorates the mushroom rapidly oyster
mushrooms are very meaty mushroom just a
lovely silky smooth flavor really nice
how do you tell uh whether it's fresh
those gills are bright never cut an
oyster mushroom always tear it look at
the whiteness of that beautiful that
would be grey if it was old
although also found wild oyster
mushrooms are more commonly cultivated
along with a similar type the enoki
their delicate taste is great in salads
and soups
finally fred saved the best until last
of course the pinnacle
is the truffle
they are really really sought after the
smell is so intense that smell
it's hard to describe because it's such
a unique smell the more expensive the
truffle the more intense the smell so
that's why you use such a small amount
on a dish it's amazing the way they get
these they used to use pigs of course
but they don't do that anymore they use
dog steel but because the pigs used to
eat them all this magical tasting fungi
is by weight one of the most expensive
foods in the world it's phenomenal eaten
raw shaved over pastel or risottos or
drizzle of truffle or turn slow cooked
stews into something out of this world
people are actually scared of mushrooms
aren't they so it's amazing really they
shouldn't be because
take away the fear and just close your
eyes and taste them they're just amazing
they are amazing
[Music]
all the ingredients in one dish helps
lock in taste and get great flavors
working together here are three recipes
that turn civil ingredients into amazing
dishes
first up a fantastically aromatic
melt-in-the-mouth treat pork neck curry
with mango salsa
[Music]
for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass
chili fresh ginger
garlic and kaffir lime leaf to a pestle
and water
next put in aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander
a pinch of salt
black pepper
[Music]
then bash it into a rough paste
finally add olive oil to loosen and your
paste is done
now onto the pork neck add a lug of
olive oil to a hot pan and brown the
diced meat carefully
making sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor
remove and in the same pan cook sliced
onions until brown around the edges
add the curry paste and fry to release
all the intense flavors
then put the pork back in along with the
coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar
more kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and
fish sauce to taste
then simply simmer for an hour
[Music]
slow cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful served with
fresh mango salsa pork make curry
my next easy slow cooked recipe is
incredible spicy szechuan chicken thighs
[Music]
first marinade the thighs with soy sauce
and shaoxing wine which is made from
fermented rice and tastes similar to dry
sherry
chicken thighs do a lot of work so they
need more cooking but cooked properly
they're moist and they're the tastiest
part of the bird
next add rice vinegar
water then season and leave to marinade
for up to two hours
then chop garlic
chili and ginger
add olive oil to a hot pan and fry until
softened
add szechuan peppercorns and orange zest
next add the marinated chicken thighs
along with a marinade
then throw in a pinch of sugar and fry
the chicken until it's lovely and brown
and the sauce is deliciously thick
[Music]
finish with chopped spring onions add
like a soy sauce and a few drops of
sesame seed oil
marinated for flavor sweet and spicy
chicken a fuss-free wonder
[Music]
my final slow cooked dish that
transforms simple ingredients into
unforgettable food is simple beef
brisket
[Music]
start by seasoning the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the breast
it's inexpensive but it's fit for
royalty with long slow cooking
place into hot casserole dish with a
little olive oil and brown on all sides
[Music]
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery
a whole bulb of garlic cut in half
peppercorns
aromatic cloves and freshly ground
nutmeg
[Music]
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours
cooked low and slow the results are
amazing tend to melt in the mouth meat
fantastic with roast potatoes or in
sandwiches with lots of mustard but i
like it best with tangy picky lily
in the oven in under 10 minutes
then all you have to do is sit back and
wait
so easy and absolutely delicious what's
not to love about my succulent beef
brisket
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
soon i'll be teaching you a wonderful
slow cooked dessert now look at the
color on them the smell
is incredible
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier
[Applause]
starting with how to cook duck breast
perfectly the slow way
duck breasts never be scared about
cooking this bird absolutely delicious
very healthy first oven on 200 degrees
and then
salt pepper
now the salt will help to extract the
water out of the fat non-stick pan no
oil but start the duck breasts in the
pan cold
skin side down it feels
and sounds a little bit weird but if you
put them into a cold pan and turn the
heat up gradually it starts to release
the fat
if we put them into a hot pan
it seals them in and the fat stays in
there we want to render that fat down
90 percent of that duck breast will be
cooked on its skin
keeps the duck nice and moist but more
importantly it stays crispy
once the fat comes out turn the duck
over
nice high hot heat
seal the duck
now they're going in the oven skin side
down
200
six to eight minutes
if your pan's got a plastic handle then
transfer the duck breast onto a tray but
make sure you put the tray into the oven
to get hot first
cooking duck is like cooking a piece of
beef and you can't slice it piping hot
all the goodness runs out
just quickly turn it over
push your fingers in there and it's
slightly
resistant but still quite bouncy and
that confirms they're quite pink in the
center but the important part now is
leaving that to rest let them cool down
and then we'll slice them
keep that excess duck fat
and there you go next time you're
sauteing potatoes you just take them to
a completely different level now slicing
the dirt just slice at an angle not too
thin if you slice it thinly it goes cold
quickly so nice thick slices
nice crispy skin on top
and a beautiful clump
roasted duck
all the white fat gone nice crispy skin
and absolutely delicious
[Music]
another slow cooking tip is when slow
cooking stews and casseroles fat will
rise to the surface
to get rid of any excess oils my tip is
to remove them with kitchen paper before
serving
[Music]
this also works brilliantly on gravies
and sauces
many great slow-cooked dishes start by
browning the meat as the meat cooks lots
of flavors get stuck to the pan to get
it into your sauce delays with wine
stock or vinegar
never add soft herbs at the beginning of
slow cooking they're all too delicate
the tip is to add them at the end for
that hit of fresh flavor and vibrant
color
a great tip when frying fish is to
always fry skin side down to keep it
crispy
and always lay the fitters away from you
when adding to the pan to prevent hot
oil from splashing towards you
[Music]
slow cooking isn't exclusive to just
savory dishes it's a clever way to
transform fruit into wonderful desserts
giving them an amazing sticky jammy
intensity
invest a bit of patience and my next
recipe pays off big time
and bursting with flavor caramelise figs
with ricotta slow cooking can also take
desserts to a whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green fix because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious
lay your figs out in rows take some
rosemary and just peel
that down
get that really nice fragrant stem get
your scissors
trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp point bring your three figs
together
and just thread
the top of each fig
nice and gently
rosemary works wonderfully with sweet
dishes as the figs roast in the oven the
stalk will impart a lovely subtle flavor
useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of balsamic
vinegar
leave them to sit there for five minutes
and they sort of marinade i know it
sounds odd to use vinegar in your
dessert but trust me it gives the dish a
fantastic sweet and sour taste i'm gonna
make a really nice caramel four or five
tablespoons of sugar
now flatten that out and get it nice and
even
when the sugar is even caramel cooks
evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in
the one thing you don't do
is shake the pan rapidly
and see it almost like sort of
a lake defrosting and it's hitting to
the center
bubbling still not dark enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas knob of butter in
there
just gently
whisk in
the butter it's cooling the caramel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe lay
next add a log of the balsamic vinegar
nice
beautiful
got that nice dark richness
of the caramel a little touch of water
in there
that way the caramel doesn't go too
thick
now put the caramel back on the heat
take your figs and sort of place them in
gently
lovely
and then just add all that lovely little
marinade
mmm don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
nice icing sugar and balsamic vinegar
there's something so tasty
baste
those figs
because the
skin
gets nice and crispy on the outside
and the fig sort of just absorbs the
caramel
delicious
so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
the smell
is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that caramel
now douse the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese
the freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
i'm gonna finish that now
with some
zest
and then
some little nibbed almonds and the rich
creamy jam texture of the fig
with the ricotta
is brilliant that is an amazing way of
slow roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
now it's time to settle down and enjoy
some slow cooked favorites
one of the brilliant things about slow
cooking is there's often very little
preparation required and it's the oven
that does all the work
my first recipe is packed with strong
confident flavors and with the oven
taking the strain is a pleasure to make
[Music]
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust and really get stuck in big
bold flavors work really well so don't
be precious this is gutsy cooking at its
absolute best
these are lamb breasts a beautiful cheap
cut and it's sort of tucked alongside
the rib they've been boned out the skin
has been taken off i'm going to roll
them stuff them and braise them braising
simply means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
season
season on both sides inside and out
really important
it doesn't look like a real weighty
dense cut of meat but once it's
beautifully slow braised it's just like
melting lamb it's incredible
i'm going to season the breasts with
some dried oregano
put a heat in there
some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
put some amazing
salty anchovies in there now they almost
melt inside the lamb
so the balance of flavors
work beautifully
now pull it down
towards you
and roll that nice and tightly
that's what i'm looking for
string
i just need to tie them
three times one at each end and one in
the middle
i fell in love with this dish years ago
when i first started working in paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
pyrenees
the nice thing is they can be done the
day before
pan on olive oil in
get that oil nice and hot lamin
really important to get
some nice color on there
whilst they're browning
slice the onion
the lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours so don't slice the onions
too thinly otherwise they'll burn
garlic and leave whole
got a color on them look at that
beautiful
take them out
onions in and garlic straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans
why
all the goodness
is in that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
oregano
nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there i'm gonna
do the onions what i did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding the bottom of the pan
they get nice and crispy
next my black olives
now
white wine
mmm
bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well
i rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there it's just
extraordinary
now
where that tomatoes
[Music]
puncher
plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
[Music]
lid on
into the oven
170
two
two and a half hours and forget about it
[Music]
whoa
beautiful
all that has reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
has kept its color look at that it's
braised beautifully
very carefully
get your little bits there slice
off pull off the little bits of string
this is why i get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
i can smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there that that is a
very cheap
cut of meat i'm salivating
i love this i mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
amazing
rich sauce
take your lamp sort of just
sit it on
it looks incredible
and that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb
with lemon anchovies chili and oregano
[Music]
slow cooking is a fantastic way to
develop delicious deep flavors here are
three of my easy one pot wonders
minimum preparation long cook and an
amazing wonderful taste
first up easy bolito misto a classic
italian mixed meat dish
[Music]
i'm starting with some italian fennel
sausages
[Music]
fry them until coloured making sure all
sides are nicely browned
set them aside then slice drizzo a spicy
spanish sausage with a wonderful smoky
taste and fry it so it releases all its
incredible flavour
[Music]
next chop carrots
celery
garlic
and add to the same pan this keeps in
all the flavor
stir in the pre-lentils these are
excellent for slow cooked dishes because
they retain their firm texture and shape
next add a bay leaf and some fresh thyme
sprigs
then the sausages go back in along with
chicken stock
simmer until the lentils are tender then
season to taste
[Music]
finely sprinkle with chopped parsley and
serve simple to prepare a cinch to make
and packed full of delicious hearty
flavors
my twist on an italian classic
magnificent easy bolito mister
[Music]
my next everyday effortless dish is slow
cooked aubergine
dice the aubergine and fry in hot olive
oil until colored on all sides
then add a finely sliced onion
and chop garlic
cook until tender
add cooked butter beans and pomegranate
molasses which is a sweet thick and
glossy tangy reduction of pomegranate
juice
season
[Music]
next add a can of chopped tomatoes
bring to a simmer and cook until the
aubergine has a gloriously soft and
silky texture
stir through chopped mint pile onto
toasted bread and finally for a lovely
salty tang crumble over some creamy feta
cheese
minimum preparation but slow cooked for
maximum flavor aubergines like you've
never tasted before
[Music]
one more dish that uses time to
transform a humble ingredient is perfect
slow cooked beef
[Music]
start by frying the beef shin in hot oil
seasoning as you go
this is a very economical cut of beef as
it slow cooks it also makes the most
delicious gravy as the marrow thickens
and flavors the sauce
[Music]
in the same pan sausage chopped carrots
peeled whole shallots
sliced celery peeled and chopped ginger
and garlic
next add tomato puree and cook for a few
minutes
[Music]
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine
and the juice of an orange this deglazes
the pan adding incredible depth of
flavor
pour in chicken stock season and simmer
for an hour and 20 minutes
this dish is brilliant finished with
gremolata a dry italian salsa made with
chopped herbs
simply chop parsley and garlic together
and mix in the zest of an orange or
lemon
when the beef is cooked rich anxious and
beautifully tender scatter over the
lovely fresh gremolata
simple satisfying and crammed full of
wonderful tastes and textures delicious
fast to prepare cheap and easy to make
slow cooked to perfection
three amazing dishes i guarantee you'll
make time and time again
[Music]
this is my essential guide to kitchen
equipment everything you need to know
about the basic kit that will get you
cooking fantastic food
casserole dish
absolutely essential when it comes to
good home cooking why so versatile the
beauty of this thing is the fact that
you can actually use it on the hob or
start it on the hob and finish in the
oven more importantly
cast iron it conducts the heat so you
can have the gas on absolute minimal or
the oven down to its absolute lowest
setting and the thing will just cook
naturally casserole dishes are
surprisingly versatile and a great
investment you only need one and if you
look after it it will last you a
lifetime
brilliant
for one pot wonders
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
[Music]
i'm teaching you my slow cooked
favorites next up my guide to getting
the best value from your butchers one of
the biggest bills in the kitchen is
going to be for meat so it's crucial you
keep costs down but that doesn't mean
sacrificing flavor especially when you
use some slow cooking magic to get the
best from cheap cuts
to get value for money it always pays to
ask an expert and fifth generation
award-winning master butcher danny
lydgate is a man in the know one of the
great things about going to a butcher is
they're going to have more cuts
available than most supermarkets so
you're going to see things that people
don't know about so one example might be
the beef ribs a great product for slow
cooking in the oven especially cooking
on the bone you're going to get more
flavors from the bone there's some
really nice pieces of juicy meat these
only used for mints in the past now
people are using it for braising or slow
braising or even barbecuing it with some
really nice marinades the ox tail are
less popular now than maybe they used to
be small little mussels make up the tail
once that's slow cooked they all fall
apart really tender juicy meat
also oxtail is sublime in stews curries
and soups
another great cheap cut for slow cooking
is one you saw me using earlier lambs
breast
[Music]
it's one of the least expensive cuts of
lamb and it's also delicious slow
roasted or stewed here we have the shin
of beef where you can see
in the shins made up of lots of little
different mussels these are always
moving always doing work so slow cooking
will give the best end results it's
going to have fashion a little bit but
it should be enjoyed by everybody it's a
fantastic piece of meat
here we have some ox cheeks and when
they're trimmed you end up with a really
lean piece of meat obviously with the
cheek the cow's always eating munching
on grass this means they need a lot of
cooking but
essentially it's a really nice healthy
lean piece of meat with fantastic
flavors
ox cheeks also make an incredible
ravioli or ragu and if you're a pork
lover why not try pork neck it's a
succulent alternative for a slow sunday
roast here we have a mussel from the
shoulder it's called feather blades
the reason it's called feather blades
because when it's cut
each piece looks like a feather the
gristle tends to be slow cooked and the
more it's cooked will turn gelatinous
giving a lovely jelly and juicy liquid
to the meat fantastic for casseroling
pies and stews there are so many cheaper
cuts which are brilliant for home
cooking it's important with all these
forgotten cuts to find out how to cook
them don't be scared of them they're
really economic but full of flavor and
the end result is fantastic meal
as a chef one of the biggest kicks i get
is taking an ingredient that doesn't
cost much and turning into something
that looks and tastes like a million
bucks
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut of meat into
the star of the dish fit to grace any
table
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
[Music]
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife
bring the pork belly towards you so
you're over it and you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife i'm just sort of
nicking it and go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife
take your time turn it
180.
this time what we're doing is just sort
of cutting these nice little sort of
diamonds but as that starts roasting on
top it starts getting nice and crispy
take
little handfuls of salt and just sort of
rub it in
bend it over in all those cracks
really helps to get a nice crisp
crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
i'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables
crush and peel three whole cloves of
garlic and add to the fennel olive oil
in
fennel in
like the
nice strong
antique flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds
delicious
star anise
in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear
the top of that fat that locks in all
that amazing flavor then i'm going to
flip it over and get it nice and crispy
and then i want fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now
some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can smell that light
fragrance from the fennel
allow the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off time
that the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there will be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and braises at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never get
up to temperature
smells incredible
slow roast a pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock
has evaporated
put that onto the board
it looks
stunning make a delicious rustic sauce
with the flavor packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat
take a couple of slices of bread it's
like a perfect sponge because you just
lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that
fat if you want the perfect fried bread
trust me
stick that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard
whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
with your pork belly
always use a nice serrated edge knife
you can hear that
that
is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy
belly of pork
what an amazing way to cook a very cheap
cut of meat
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first how to make a fantastic chicken
stock a classic slow cook recipe that
gets amazing flavor from simple
ingredients
chicken stock the vital ingredient to
good cooking it transforms sauces it's a
fantastic base for soups and more
importantly it's so easy to do a little
bit of love and care at the beginning
and it cooks itself right step one
chicken carcass into a pie sided
an onion
doesn't need to be finely chopped the
vegetables flavor the stock
onion in
then from there cut your leek into nice
big solid chunks
roughly same size as the onion
so the vegetables cook at the same time
and then our carrot
celery in
garlic
and then a nice
sprig of thyme that helps to really give
depth of flavor to the chicken stock a
couple of bay leaves
and some fresh parsley
and then
peppercorns
pan
and just lightly crush them
and a little pinch of salt
and now just cover the vegetables and
the carcass with cold water
just cover the chicken and the
vegetables
bring it up to the ball as quick as you
can
now as it comes into the boil a really
nice skin
take the base of the ladle and swirl
that around that pushes
all the grease and the impurities to the
side of the pan then get your ladle and
just tilt it
if you don't skim
all that off
the stock becomes very cloudy
people's impression of cooking stock
that it needs to cook for three four
hours at a time this is one chicken
carcass let that boil away gently for 30
to 40 minutes maximum
now
we're going to pass it off
take a sieve
place that over
the pan
and then just
pour that in
it smells amazing
it's aromatic
the color is absolutely beautiful
and there you have
the most amazing stock
when you need to season meat in flour a
great tip is to place it in a plastic
bag to dust it evenly using flour also
helps the sauce to get nice and thick
during cooking
when browning meat fry in small batches
don't crowd the pan otherwise it won't
sear or color properly
when slow roasting meat line the bottom
of the roasting tray with chunky
vegetables like onions fennel and
carrots they act as a trivet to keep the
meat from boiling in its own juices plus
the veg can be the base for your gravy
later on
after slow cooking baked on residue can
be tough to remove but if you boil water
in the pan it will dissolve and break
down then simply pour out and wash with
soap and water
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store
you